hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on foreigner again and
we have another April Fool's Day kind of
thing going on with the game we're gonna
be talking about that in today's video
it's nothing too crazy I don't know if
it's actually in-game yet but there is a
little Twitter video about this but as
always like three if you do enjoy
subscribe refrain ooh that covered the
informational side of for nerd that
being the balance changes the hero
updates the patch notes and the leaks
if only kept us today with everything
happening then the world of Warner I
never miss out on an update that ways to
subscribe the channel and with that
let's get started with today's video so
like I stated we're gonna be talking
about the obelisk again and if you've
been playing the game for about the past
year or so this might ring a bell and
you might understand what I'm talking
about for the new players that don't
understand about last year April 2019 on
April 1st we got a little bit of a joke
event or one-day event that was really
interesting where the minions all
changed to the rave raving rabbids and
it wasn't really much to it it was
really just the minions being changed
and obviously that was just as fun as it
was there was no weapons no armor no
nothing like that just a nice little
one-day surprise and they went away
after the day which was pretty funny
though but regardless of how people
thought about it I honestly thought it
was a really fun event a nice way to
kind of chill out during in between the
seasons and stuff but according to this
date if it's supposed to be April 1st is
actually the second last day of the
Prince of Persia event so maybe this
will be a nice way to kind of send off
the event with another small one-day
thing happening at this exact time but
who knows but as to this new obelisk in
this for second Twitter video it seems
to be shown on the map shard and I don't
necessarily know why but I think we
figured out from last year that the
should where the obelisks obelisks are
that's a really hard word to say it does
don't actually matter it's just really
if you find them you need to look at
what they say and on the front it says
stuff about it looks like a sword and I
don't actually know where this fits in
with any of the characters or any of the
Ubisoft games that they have but also
technically if you remember from last
year they had this really weird
obelisk looking thing that was in all
the maps and the icon on it just said
they are coming even though that was in
a teaser the actual image didn't
we make a whole lot of sense and at
least to me I have never really played
any of the Rabbids games this icon
really doesn't connect that icon to the
game at all but if it does then maybe
I'm wrong and this does have something
to do with it but released from me I'm
not really sure what this sword could
entail because I'm trying to think of
Ubisoft games or other things that they
could have created and I can't really
think of anything so this is going to be
future me while I'm editing I actually
did take a look at the map chart and it
is there and I do have an up close
version of the picture it seems to be a
sword with the middle kind of chipped
away I'm not really sure at what the
point of that is but then it looks like
there is four character sitting on top
of the sword doing all various actions
dodging moving etc and they do seem to
be two or four different characters I'm
thinking warlord is towards the middle
with the sword out T on D it seems to be
on the side of warden seems to be on the
top and I can't really tell who that is
but that could be Orochi that is doing
the sum result so maybe this has to do
with the four characters this is a lot
more info than we got when it came to
the other items so I'm wondering it
really curious now what this might
actually entail like I said four
characters all on a sword I don't know
if we're gonna be doing some King
Arthur's sword in the stone type [ __ ]
but I don't really think that's the case
but maybe it is I guys have to let me
know in the comments below what you
think yeah with that like the V if you
do enjoy guys subscribe if you're new I
cover the informational side of
foreigner that being the balance changes
to hear if they stuff hatchets in the
leaks thank y'all for watching the video
today let me know in the comments below
what you guys think this is in reference
to and peace out I'll see y'all next
week for whatever this happens to be
goodbye
[Music]
you
[Music]